Rex Tillerson is Donald Trump's choice
for Secretary of State the former CEO of
oil giant ExxonMobil is not even in
office yet and he's already creating
diplomatic waves in the South China Sea
we've got to step back and look at all
all of China's activities and the one
you mentioned now the the island
building in in the South China Sea the
the declaration of control of airspace
in waters of over the sea ke ku Islands
with Japan both of those are illegal
actions they're taking they're taking
territory or control or declaring
control of territories that are not
rightfully China's China's state
controlled media were quick to denounced
Ellison's statement the government run
Global Times even issued an indirect
warning that Washington should remember
that China is a nuclear power China
claims sovereignty over 80% of the South
China Sea an area of ocean between China
Malaysia the Philippines and Vietnam
which includes several island groups
Beijing has constructed artificial
islands in the region and stationed
troops and missiles on them the natural
island chains are claimed by several
countries most of them US allies but
Beijing made it clear it is not going to
let Washington tell it what to do like
the US China also completely has the
right to conduct any normal activities
in its sovereign territory and that is
indisputable Donald Trump lashed out at
Beijing several times during his
election campaign but Tillison in the
past has been one of the more moderate
voices in the Republican camp also
pointing to China's economic might and
its role in the global fight against
militant Islamists so till essence
tough-talking on China may turn out to
be just rhetoric when an if Tillison
takes office and realpolitik kicks in